this is real so my good friend Kevin is
obsessed with mini-pigs
he only follows mini-pigs on Instagram
he talks about them all the time but
unfortunately his landlord has a no pet
policy so he can't get one but today is
his birthday and we wanted to make it
really special so we're here in his
apartment to surprise it with two baby
pigs also this is the very first time
that kevin is going to hold a mini pig
and so I think his reactions gonna be
pretty awesome oh ma is this real
Oh heaven you can bet them there's oh my
god
my heart I can't handle this oh they're
so scared of me cry I just want to make
them happy
I'm gonna buy a little hat I've only
seen them pictures oh my god
this is a spiritual moment I don't know
why I love pigs more than any other
animal but it's something about like
little nose and little tail and their
noises it's it's just so adorable I
always tried to convince my mom hey we
should get a little pig never let me
have one definitely the greatest day of
my life I'm ready to buy ten of these
immediately objectively so that I can
lay down and just let them like run all
over me and color with them that will be
how I do stress every single day ha I've
lived the greatest moment of my life
it's all downhill from here
[Music]